Hey, if you haven't already got it. Get yourself a copy of answer. The internet,
the card game is available right now in the link in the bio.
Or you can get at Barstool sports, Walmart, Amazon,
or Spencer gifts play along with us. Let's get it.
What's up. It's your boy KSI. Make sure you check out my track down like that.
Uh, this is a special surprise in that, uh, especially in the music videos.
See if you can find that.
[Inaudible].
Would you ever have your poem, such history shed with you?
Twitter followers or your parents? Uh, probably my parents. Yeah.
They'll probably charge me less. Yeah. They'll probably just be like, yeah,
I expected that from him. Ted tattoo, Boston. Yeah.
I need to get out, get roasted with the things I search. Yeah, for sure.
Uh, how long would you have to stop to become accountable? Oh, wow.
Um, maybe a couple of days bro.
Aye. Boy,
if I'm hungry I'm I can't eat anyone if I can't eat
like food that's bro.
Yeah, bro. I'm gonna knock you out and then eat you bro. I'm sorry, man.
Uh, probably legs. Yeah, but I look like a weirdo.
If every time you go a Buena, the same song would start playing.
What song would you want? Um,
down like that. Yeah.
Yeah. Go down like that. You know,
if you can make any two people fight in the no rules, cage match.
Who would you choose? Uh,
I think Putin and Trump. I think that'd be insane.
I think Putin would win, but I mean, I'll be on the.
Rail.
Oh, CRO. I bought, well,
I'd pay whatever to watch that. If you had one free throw,
I you wait and if you make it, you got a million dollars, but if you miss,
you never get to text again. Would you shoot it? Uh, no,
but I've got money, so yeah.
10 minute. Nah. Uh, yeah, maybe a hundred.
Should you look a dog out of the room when you're having sex? Yeah,
No, let's say like, he's just in there. When you start.
Are you going to stop and get him and move him out and lock them out?
Yeah. Yeah. Nah, they don't don't even see that, man.
[inaudible].
Like fully participated when he's trying to get kissed.
Oh my gosh. Start licking the rug.
Uh, would you ever have your Dick as your nose or your nose?
I showed Dick mine. Um,
uh, I think, um, uh, Dick is my nose.
No, no. So my Dick is a nose. Yeah.
My Dick is a nose. Yeah. Now I can have like a Dick on my face, man.
That's a horrible sideband would you rather have a rewind button or a
pose, but all pause. Pause. Yeah. I think pause would be sick,
dude. I talk too much fun. Yeah.
I with people so hard. Yeah. Pause for sure. I think rewind.
Yeah. No.
Can I pause right now and just switch your clothes?
Nah, I just make people naked. I just
Know. Yeah, it'd be. Uh,
would you a porn star if afterward she had to hold a press conference
on your poop full. Oh man. Um, yeah,
yeah, yeah. Both.
Yeah, both. I mean be funny. Yeah. Uh,
would you rather fight a short gladiator or rhino?
Um, probably, uh, a short gladiator.
I pulled out the rhino would properly me up. I, I feel,
I feel like I wouldn't knock it out.
I think it would be hard to knock out a rhino. Yeah.
Yeah.
Uh, would you ever lose a leg or never be able to have say, Oh gee, Ooh.
I'll never be able to have sex again. Oh man.
But then if I lost the leg, the, my, the people I can have sex,
it kind of reduces.
True. Then you got to get really rich.
But then I guess it's sex is just like intercourse. Right? So I can,
I even do like oil and. I can do oral.
Uh, no, no, no, no, no, no. [inaudible].
Well all type of sexual. Oh man.
Oh, I don't know. That's I TOF mine.
it. I might, I might just.
[Inaudible].
Oh, I lose leg. Yeah. I lose a leg.
it.
[Inaudible].